[Music]
hey guys it's matt welcome back to my
kitchen my friend from india is
challenging me to use an ingredient i've
never tried before so rather than
explain it myself i'll let her take over
hey matt this is shreya from buzzfeed
india and today i have a challenge for
you this packet beholds a flavor that is
loved and cherished by our entire nation
these are masala flavored instant
noodles called maggi that you can whip
up in less than two minutes but usually
it takes much longer here in india
everyone has a unique way of making
maggie some like a dry some like it's
soupy some like it with cheese cheese
you can add any favorite topping of
yours to maggie and i promise you it
will taste just delicious so for this
challenge i want to see if you can add
your own chef's twist to maggie and make
it into a recipe that will blow my mind
show me what you can do and i will
remake it here in india and we can then
figure out if you nailed it or failed it
so good luck to you matt and i cannot
wait to see what you make out of maggie
alright shreya i accept your challenge i
don't know where to find maggie
maybe i might have an idea so right now
i am actually heading to an indian
grocery store that's kind of near my
house i don't know if they carry the
noodles but i think they do they've got
a pretty good selection of stuff
[Music]
alrighty that was way easier than i
thought it was going to be i got
one gigantic packet of maggie two
smaller ones for good measure you don't
know maybe i'll like it i also got
assorted snacks because i have zero
impulse control let's make some maggie
noodles shall we
break the noodle cake into four parts
oh that was easy
was it supposed to break all apart
add the noodle cake and contents of the
spice mix packet to a pan
oh no cook for two minutes in an open
pan stirring occasionally do not drain
remaining water here we go
it smells good i'm getting very like
ramen instant ramen vibes
this definitely falls into the superior
category so i'm gonna try making it dry
just to see what it's about i'm not
quite sure if there's a particular way
to make it dry so i just boil the
noodles drain the water off and then
sprinkle the seasoning over the top
the seasoning
the seasoning is definitely a lot more
pronounced here but i think i think i
prefer the soupy one more treya also
mentioned that you can make it with
cheese so i think i'm gonna try it that
way just to kind of see what's up i'm
gonna be honest i will try everything
once but i'm very skeptical of this
honestly not bad it's something to
consider it reminds me of a very
well-seasoned noodley mac and cheese
with those three methods in mind i'm
gonna go to the grocery store and let's
try and make something with it
[Music]
so i think i'm going to attempt to make
a fried chicken sandwich using maggie
noodles and the seasoning in my mind
this is going to be something similar to
like a chicken katsu so it's breaded on
the outside nice and thin fits on a
slice of bread i'm going to use my
noodles as the breading on the outside
of the chicken grind these babies up
in the hole
whoa
[Music]
nice it's not too fine it feels almost
similar to panko bread crumbs i do want
to elevate this just a little bit so i'm
going to add a little bit of my
seasoning save a little bit for later
give this all a good stir and i think as
far as breading goes that's where i'm
going to leave it for now so in one
station i have my flower and then number
two
give it a nice beak
and that should be good
and then i'm generously seasoning with a
little salt and the rest of this is
pretty self-explanatory pop her in the
flour
nice and coated beauteous got my egg
mixture
and get nice and coated finally nice
nice little shake get off all our excess
wow
i'm just gonna let this camp in the
fridge for like half an hour to make
sure everything kind of meshes together
and we'll be back at it whenever i'm
having a super meaty sandwich whether
it's barbecue or fried chicken i like
adding slaw on top so i'm to stick with
that theme today as well i have thinly
shredded cabbage here to which i'm going
to add some thinly sliced red onion a
little bit of grated ginger some fresh
squeezed lime juice a little bit of
olive oil and finally some cilantro give
that all a good stir
wow actually good and i'm pretty happy
with how the slaws turned out so i'm
going to set it aside and move along i
want to add a bit of creaminess and
spice to balance everything else i've
got going on in my sandwich and to do
that i want to use mayo just elevate it
a little bit to my mayo i'm going to add
the rest of my masala seasoning and then
to kick things up a bit a little bit of
cayenne pepper get all of that
beautifully incorporated
oh my god i could put this on everything
i'm done with all my toppings so let's
fry some chicken
i've got a pan here heat it over medium
heat i'm going to add my oil
i'm going to let this go for three to
four minutes and then check and see if
it's brown on the other side
and
yeah
this is looking great so far i'm just
gonna let this go for another three to
four minutes i like my bread toasted i'm
going to take my mayo
generously top it with my slaw and
finally my piece of chicken which is so
big i don't know how to orient it oh
[Music]
my god i mean this looks really good
let's get a nice little cross section
though
wow
oh my goodness
okay that looks great
i don't want to get too excited for too
overly confident but this is awesome
everything works well together it's
crunchy it's juicy it's acidic it's
creamy i would absolutely make this
again this is fantastic in my opinion
[Music]
oh i'm going to send this recipe to
shreya she's going to recreate it and
we'll see how that goes
so i have matt's recipe right here i am
so excited to eat this my first thought
when i saw the recipe was why has he
made a 2-minute recipe into a 20-minute
recipe oh no
but i guess i'm about to find out how it
tastes
it just looks so good
[Music]
i don't even think i have to say this
you didn't feel it you nailed it
congratulations i love this recipe the
flavors are so much right now my mouth
is loving it my mouth's having a party
the crunch of the veggies and that lime
in there and the masala and the
tenderness of the chicken and the
toasted bread
oh my god you guys should 100 try this
recipe and let us know in the comments
below if matt nailed it or failed it if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you subscribe to bus food in
buzzfeed india where we post a lot of
videos like this oh and matt the spice
in the maggie really hits you the next
day so good luck for that and i'm outta
here bye
[Music]
you